ya estamos listos para hablar sobre
algunas tendencias generales en la tabla
periódica y lo primero que se ve en la
mayoría de los cursos de química es la
energía de ionización la energía de
ionización es la energía que se necesita
para quitar un electrón de la versión
neutra de un átomo
vamos a ver energía para quitar
un electrón
y en caso de que no se acuerden de que
es unión se los explicaré unión es un
átomo o molécula bueno las moléculas son
combinaciones o grupos de átomos unidos
de alguna forma entonces un guión es un
átomo o molécula en donde el número de
protones que tiene no es igual al número
de electrones entonces tenemos alguna
carga por ejemplo si tenemos más
protones que electrones tendremos una
carga positiva digamos que tenemos
hidrógeno normalmente es neutro no tiene
carga pero supongamos que le queremos
quitar un electrón entonces nos quedaría
un hidrógeno más un electrón como el
hidrógeno solamente tiene un electrón se
quedaría con un protón así que tiene
la carga positiva más 1 y aquí podemos
escribir menos 1 emoción izado el
hidrógeno es decir le hemos quitado un
electrón y en este caso como el guión de
hidrógeno termina con una carga positiva
cuando unión tiene una carga positiva le
llamamos catión este es un camión ahora
digamos que tenemos cloro cl
en su forma estable tiene 7 electrones
de valencia pero si agregamos otro
electrón entonces tendrá 8 electrones lo
que le da una carga negativa
este es un ión negativo y se le conoce
como unión
unión tiene el prefijo a que significa
lo opuesto entonces el avión es unión
negativo y el camión es unión positivo
pero la energía de ionización en
realidad debería llamarse energía de
categorización porque no es la energía
que se necesita para quitar o agregar un
electrón sino más bien es la energía
necesaria para convertir algo en un
camión
entonces ya conocemos la tabla periódica
pero a qué elementos será más difícil
quitarle un electrón ya qué elementos
será más fácil bueno empecemos con el
grupo 1 que sería este grupo
el grupo de los metales alcalinos dejaré
el hidrógeno fuera ya hemos hablado
mucho de estos elementos dijimos que
para lograr el mágico número 8 necesitan
deshacerse de un electrón en su última
capa electrónica como por ejemplo el
potasio tiene un electrón de valencia
en su cuarta capa y al deshacerse de ese
electrón entonces se queda con 8
electrones que es la configuración
electrónica del argón y eso sería muy
bueno así que estos elementos donarán un
electrón fácilmente entonces se necesita
baja energía para poder guionizar los
baja energía de ionización pero
qué me dicen de estos elementos qué tan
difícil es quitarle un electrón al neón
por ejemplo bueno el neón ya está
completo no quiere ni reaccionar o
unirse a otro átomo ya es feliz y no
quiere que nadie le quite sus electrones
entonces tanto al neón crypton argón o
cualquier elemento de los gases nobles
les gusta conservar sus electrones así
que para poder quitarles un electrón se
necesita mucha energía alta energía en
la tabla periódica la tendencia es ir de
baja energía a mayor energía a muchas
personas les gusta memorizar esto pero
en realidad sólo es cuestión de observar
e identificar que a estos elementos les
gusta donar su electrón
estos elementos tienen dos electrones y
también los quieren donar pero en este
caso al donar un electrón no ocurre lo
mismo que con ellos porque estos
elementos al donar su electrón pasan
directamente al estado más estable así
que la tendencia es confiable
este elemento por ningún motivo quiere
regalar un electrón y este elemento se
encuentra tan cerca del neón que por
ningún motivo quiere parecerse al
oxígeno no quiere donar su electrón así
que la tendencia es muy clara cada vez
que no recuerden la tendencia sólo
observen los casos extremos
este elemento quiere donar electrones y
este elemento los quiere ganar pero cuál
es la energía que se necesita para
quitar un electrón bueno este elemento
prácticamente se los dará sin esfuerzo
que para este elemento será muy difícil
especialmente con el neón pero que
sucede al bajar bueno ya dijimos que los
metales alcalinos están dispuestos a
donar electrones pero al ir hacia abajo
de la tabla periódica el electrón puede
estar más lejos del núcleo como por
ejemplo en el caso del cesio sería el
electrón número 55 en el átomo neutro
también hay 55 protones y el electrón
número 55 está más lejos del núcleo que
el electrón número 3 en el caso del
litio y lo mismo ocurre con la atracción
electrón núcleo entonces como el último
electrón cada vez se encuentra más y más
lejos del núcleo conforme bajamos en la
tabla periódica eso significa que este
elemento está más desesperado por
regalar sus
electrones que el litio así que no es
necesario memorizar la tendencia porque
al memorizar quizá les sea útil para un
examen pero después cuando tengan 42
años y alguien les pregunte qué elemento
tiene mayor energía de ionización el
cesio o el flúor quizás ya no lo
recuerden pero al ver una tabla
periódica podrán decir que el cesio está
desesperado por donar un electrón pero
en el caso del flúor solo necesita un
electrón para convertirse en neón y el
neón es muy feliz todos sus electrones
se encuentran en la configuración más
estable
hay mucha atracción definitivamente no
quiere regalar sus electrones entonces
si hablamos de la energía que se
necesita para quitar un electrón
necesitamos baja energía para el cesio y
muy alta energía para
esa es la tendencia este elemento está
más dispuesto a donar sus electrones y
este elemento los quiere conservar aquí
les tengo una gráfica de las energías de
ionización para cada elemento observen
que hay un patrón entonces este punto
corresponde al hidrógeno la energía de
ionización del hidrógeno es de
aproximadamente 13 y medio electrón
volts aunque lo podemos convertir a
jules y de repente tenemos helio que es
más estable y se necesita casi el doble
de energía para quitarle un electrón
luego bajamos hasta litio
el litio tiene un número atómico de 3
litio para quitar un electrón de litio
sólo necesitamos 5 electrón volts menos
de la mitad de lo que necesitábamos para
el hidrógeno y conforme avanzamos hacia
la derecha en la tabla periódica la
energía de ionización aumenta hasta
llegar al neón que es completamente
feliz y si agregamos un electrón
entonces tenemos al sodio la energía de
ionización cae incluso es más baja que
la de litio esta es la tendencia todos
estos elementos son gases nobles helio
es muy difícil de quitarle un electrón
neón muy difícil pero no tanto como
helio porque el neón es un poco más
grande así que los electrones se
encuentran un poco más lejos del núcleo
argón ocurre lo mismo pero
observen que el árbol no es muy
diferente del hidrógeno con el crypton
ya no es tan difícil quitarle un
electrón como al hidrógeno luego tenemos
xenón y finalmente ratón pero porque la
distancia entre estos elementos aumenta
bueno en la tabla periódica al pasar de
argón los elementos empiezan a llenar
sus orbitales de entonces antes del
argón los elementos llenan orbitales s&p
s&p y luego estos elementos empiezan a
llenar sus orbitales de hay más espacios
por llenar más espacios por llenar y
finalmente antes de llegar al ratón los
elementos se empiezan a llenar sus
orbitales
efe y es por eso que la distancia se
incrementa
conforme nos movemos hacia la derecha en
la tabla periódica se vuelve más y más
difícil quitar un electrón porque todos
quieren tener el mágico número 8 y es
muy difícil quitar un electrón a un gas
noble pero luego este elemento quiere
donar su electrón ahora si nos movemos
hacia abajo en un grupo en este caso
tenemos a los gases nobles la energía de
ionización disminuye porque el radio del
átomo aumenta así que los electrones de
valencia en el ratón no están tan cerca
del núcleo como los electrones en
nuestro helio de eso se trata la energía
de ionización hablaré más sobre esto en
otro vídeo